Former New Jersey Governor
Chris Christie, who's challenging
Donald Trump for the 2024
Republican presidential nomination
and is one of the former
president's most vocal critics
says he was actually questioned
in one of the Trump investigations,
although he will not reveal which one.
He did
tell Kara Swisher on her podcast
that he was honest in his answers.
He also says he believes Trump fears
that he could go to jail.
Listen to this.
I think there's no doubt in my mind
that more nights than not
where he's in Bedminster or at Mar
a Lago,
he lays down
a bed, the lights go out,
and he stared at the ceiling thinking
I could go to jail, I could go to jail,
All right.
Let's get some more on
what Chris Christie had to say.
Joining us
now is Kara Swisher,
the host of the podcast
On with Kara Swisher.
Kara, thanks very much for joining us.
He revealed to you
that he's been interviewed
in one of these Trump
related investigations.
What else did he tell you?
Well, he talked about a lot of things,
but I think it's
probably the January 6th investigation
is my guess
of what he was talking about,
because he was referring
to his state of mind and his intent
during the insurrection,
I think, or about the election fraud.
But he said a lot of stuff.
He was talking about his state of mind.
He talked a lot about obviously the break
for lots of reasons.
And I think he feels as if he has a lane
to be in,
even though he's way down in the polls.
Everybody's way down in the polls.
But there's a lane if Donald Trump
has more legal problems
and can't continue the race, that's that
that's his bad,
I guess, where
he thinks he can still win
the Republican nomination.
Is that what he told you?
Well, he said he's going to
give me an interview.
So I don't know.
But I you know,
I maybe I'll be president.
I'll give him an interview.
But but he
I think he thinks there is is a lane here
for someone else.
Who's not Donald Trump,
you know,
their political opponents,
Christie and Trump.
But Christie knows Trump really well.
Yeah. Very close.
What else
he said about some insight
he had into Trump's thinking right now?
Well,
I think he thinks he's scared of
going to jail.
And I think he's probably right.
He's talking
he recounted a dinner
that he had with him
where the Christie had
with Trump, with Trump.
And he and he talked about
someone who was going to jail.
Powerful.
This is years and years ago,
I think it was in a New Jersey senator
of some sort of state senator
and Trump
kept saying he's really going to jail.
He's really going to jail
and seemed terrified with what
Christie seemed to indicate.
And that was interesting.
But that he
that he cannot imagine
finally having to to to pay
legal the legal price that looks like
he may have to buy this.
Christie believe
that Trump could wind up going to jail.
I think he does. I'm not.
So I push back on that
because I felt like
they're probably putting a president in
jail is probably
there's some deal to be made or simply
but he definitely thought
the possibility
was there
because of the possibility of jail time
hanging over his head.
But until then
he would take advantage of it
and raise money
which he's already done
which you did the next day.
Christie obviously is running
as a Republican right now.
He is a Republican,
but he seems to be taking
a very different tone
on this investigation. Listen to this.
I don't really think there's
anything political
about what Jack Smith is doing.
How effective is that?
Calling it a witch hunt
and stuff like that?
It seems to be effective
among his supporters.
I think it's effective
I think once you get to a courtroom, it's
not effective at all. Right.
Which is what happened
with the election law. That's right.
Yeah.
So what do you think?
You think voters are listening
to him, to Christie
because the polls show
that most of these Republicans
don't believe Trump did anything wrong.
They they do.
They do believe that.
And I think
I think
ultimately he's
talking to suburban
voters, maybe independent
voters, Republicans
that are persuadable,
I guess, or independent
people that are persuadable.
And that's what I think
he's talking about, is
that people are tired of it.
And I have several Trump
fans in my family.
And I think they're tired of it.
They're tired of the cases.
They they certainly aren't
rallying around Trump the way they were.
What do you think of Trump today?
You know,
going out there
and suggesting he's some sort of martyr,
I think,
and then getting into a giant limo tour
and his own plane
with tons of lawyers?
I don't know I think
I think the thing is
people are tired of it.
There's sort of this silent
majority of people
who are tired of anything.
They worry about their kids.
They worry about the economy, their jobs.
I think they're tired of the circus.
And that's what it is, is a circus.